Voici la structure un peu de ce qu'on va traverser aujourd'hui.
Donc on a passé la première partie de cette série d'études sur cette doctrine,
sur les chapitres 6 de la confession de foi, Baptiste, 1689.
Donc c'est les chapitres qui traitent de la chute du péché et du châtiment.
Dans la première partie, on était plus concentré sur une exposition biblique.
C'est-à-dire qu'il fallait vraiment s'habituer avec les principaux récits bibliques
qui nous montrent les narratives, l'histoire, l'enregistrement historique de ce qui s'est passé.
De cette manière, on a pu s'habituer avec l'épisode historique qui était la chute en elle-même.
On a pu commencer à comprendre les fonctionnements, rien que par la lecture naturelle du texte,
de comment cette chute a lieu à partir d'un état originel, parfait.
Et donc on a vu comment les tentations sont très similaires à chaque fois qu'on va croiser les tentations avec les péchés.
Nous avons compris un peu, par des terminologies bibliques et par la contemplation des textes principaux,
quelle était l'idée de ce qu'il y a les péchés, ce qui est très important pour nous.
Et nous avons compris aussi quels étaient les châtiments, quelles étaient les conséquences.
Certaines conséquences étaient des conséquences naturelles, immédiates.
Mais comme l'épêché a été quelque chose de commise, comme une transgression dans un cadre d'une relation d'alliance,
c'était à partir du pacte que Dieu avait établi par rapport aux fruits,
que les péchés attendent sa compréhension plus complète.
Il n'est pas tout simplement sortir du cadre de notre obéissance originale naturelle,
c'est de transgresser volontairement une loi qui a été communiquée
et qui a été formalisée dans cette relation entre Dieu et l'homme.
On a vu que c'est important de saisir toutes ces pistes bibliques, toutes ces évidences bibliques
pour que nous puissions comprendre aussi que la manière dont Dieu va traiter les péchés,
la manière dont Dieu va nous réconcilier avec lui,
ça va passer aussi par ces catégories d'envoyer son Fils pour nous substituer dans une alliance légale.
Donc les prochains chapitres de la confession de foi,
c'est les chapitres sur l'alliance des dieux avec l'homme
et notamment cette alliance des grâces
qui est fondée et précédée par une alliance éternelle,
intra-trinitaire pour notre salut.
Mais pour l'instant, et c'est ça l'importance de respecter l'ordre biblique des révélations
et l'ordre de la confession de foi
qui nous équipe à mieux comprendre l'évangile.
Donc pourquoi la Bible commence avec cet état parfait,
la chute et la compréhension de ces premiers pactes,
c'est pour nous équiper, pour qu'on puisse comprendre la révélation progressive
de la rédemption qui va suivre, qui va se suivre en fait pour toute la Bible.
Donc toute la Bible va développer cette compréhension de la rédemption.
Donc on a dû finir la semaine dernière,
il y a deux semaines pour la semaine dernière.
Bon, la dernière fois qu'on était ensemble,
on a dû finir avec l'exposition sur les proto-évangiles.
Donc on a considéré que ce même Dieu
qui nous avait exhortés par rapport aux conséquences de la transgression,
donc certainement nous allions mourir,
c'est le même Dieu qui, au moment où il vient apporter cette condamnation,
il va aussi communiquer la première version embryonnaire de l'évangile.
Donc on a considéré la beauté de savoir que c'est Dieu
qui, même si les péchés abondaient,
il vient lui-même communiquer l'espoir
par une alliance aussi des grâces.
Et donc à partir de là, on a considéré les proto-évangiles
et on est passé à une introduction,
la semaine dernière, du péché originel.
Et donc, ces chapitres en termes de doctrine,
la chose qu'il va plus vouloir expliquer ou communiquer,
c'est ce que dans la théologie,
on va nommer les péchés originels.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire par péché originel ?
Donc on va revenir à la confession de foi
et nous allons continuer de considérer
cette compréhension de ce qui était des péchés originels.
Donc les premiers paragraphes de la confession de foi,
c'est un paragraphe qui fait un résumé
du récit biblique à propos de la chute.
C'est comme si on était devant tout simplement
la communication fidèle de l'événement en soi.
Donc c'est comme si on était en train de lire
tout simplement la narrative biblique
en réprécisant des points qu'on ne peut pas rater.
Donc on peut lire ensemble les paragraphes 1 qui dit
« Bien que Dieu ait créé l'homme droit et parfait,
il lui ait donné une loi juste
qui était en vue de la vie s'il avait observé
et qu'il ait menacé des morts s'il la transgressait. »
L'homme n'ait pas gardé longtemps cet honneur,
utilisant subtilement les serpents.
Satan séduisit Ève,
donc là c'est l'interprétation littérale
des satans faisant osage du serpent,
et par elle il séduisit Adam,
qui s'encontrante sur lui,
transgressa volontairement la loi de leur création
et les commandements qui leur avaient été donnés
en mangeant du fruit défendu.
Donc remarquez très bien ces deux aspects
qui ont été précisément registrés
par les rédacteurs de la confession.
C'est-à-dire, d'un côté,
il a transgressé volontairement
la loi de leur création,
c'est-à-dire d'agir naturellement
en obéissance envers les créateurs,
envers la manière dont il nous a créés
de manière originelle,
mais il a aussi,
cet autre aspect,
les commandements qui leur avaient été donnés
en mangeant du fruit défendu.
Il a plus à Dieu de permettre cette chute
dans son conseil sage et sang,
puisqu'il avait déterminé de l'utiliser
pour manifester sa gloire.
Donc, cette dernière déclaration,
c'est pour connecter cet épisode
qui est un mystère pour nous,
comment les péchés ont pu rentrer dans le cœur
des êtres qui ont été créés originellement parfaits,
et c'est pour encadrer cette difficulté
de compréhension qu'on a
dans les cadres de la doctrine
qu'on a déjà étudiée,
qui est la doctrine de la providence
et la doctrine des décrets éternels des dieux.
C'est-à-dire,
tous ceux qui Dieu planifient,
il n'y a jamais un plan B,
la rédemption n'a jamais été un plan B pour Dieu,
c'était toujours les plans A,
et donc les dieux qui planifient toutes les choses
et qui décrètent toutes les choses,
ils gouvernent toutes les choses,
mais sans être l'agent direct du mal.
Donc, selon ce qui est un mystère pour nous,
il y a des choses que Dieu peut permettre
et que nous, en tant qu'agent véritable,
légitime, responsable,
c'est de notre faute de commettre les calculsations,
et Dieu va gouverner ces choses
de manière à conduire à des fins glorieuses,
en faisant usage même des mauvaises actions
des êtres humains.
Donc, Judas a été responsabilisé
pour la faute qu'il avait commise,
mais Judas était aussi un moyen
à travers lequel Dieu était en train d'accomplir
les plans les plus glorieux,
la rédemption à travers Jésus-Christ.
Mais donc là, c'est une permission des dieux
pour qu'ils puissent révéler davantage sa gloire
par la grâce qu'il va révéler
à travers les plans de la rédemption en Jésus-Christ.
Donc, on passe au deuxième paragraphe
et c'est à partir de là
que nous sommes introduits
dans la compréhension de cette doctrine
du péché originel.
Qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire par là ?
On va comprendre.
Donc, voici la manière dont le paragraphe 2
va nous expliquer.
Donc, par ces péchés,
nos premiers parents ont perdu leur justice originelle
et les reconvions avec Dieu.
Et nous, en eux,
de ces faits,
la mort est venue sur tous.
Tous sont devenus morts dans les péchés
et entièrement suyés
dans toutes les facultés
et les parties de leur âme
et de leur corps.
Et donc, ici,
nous sommes en train de voir
une déclaration confessionnelle
qui est en train de lier
la condition dans laquelle
l'humanité se trouve aujourd'hui.
Donc, voilà pourquoi on parle
de l'universalité du péché.
C'est que, peu importe
à quel moment de l'histoire
on regarde,
on va toujours trouver
les pages sanglantes de l'histoire.
On va toujours trouver
la méchanceté humaine,
la cruauté humaine.
Et même si,
dans tous les pages de l'histoire,
on voit que les êtres humains
sont capables
de reconnaître les vertus,
d'avoir une moralité,
nous savons qu'on ne trouve jamais
un être humain
qui arrive à vivre
à la hauteur
de ses propres paramètres
des moralités.
Et donc, la réalité,
c'est que l'universalité du péché
est l'une des plus grandes évidences.
Et la grande question
qu'on se pose à partir de là,
c'est comment est-ce qu'on est arrivé
à ces points ?
Comment on est arrivé
à un point où nous sommes une race
qui a des aspirations morales
qui peuvent être même parfaites
et en même temps,
constater l'incapacité universelle
d'agir de manière moralement satisfactoire ?
Et donc,
quand on contemple
l'universalité du péché
qui est déclarée partout
dans la parole des dieux,
la question qu'on se pose,
c'est comment nous sommes arrivés
à ces points ?
Donc, en Esaïe 53,
verset 6,
« Nous étions tous errants
comme des brébis,
chacun suivait sa propre voie
et l'Éternel a fait retomber
sur lui, sur Christ,
l'iniquité de nous tous. »
Donc, l'universalité du péché
est déclarée.
Romain, chapitre 1,
jusqu'au chapitre 3,
verset 18,
« La colère des dieux
se révèle du ciel
contre toute impiété
et toute injustice des hommes
qui retiennent injustement
la vérité captive. »
Donc, la vérité des dieux,
elle est là,
mais nous voulons plutôt
supprimer.
Et la description,
c'est qu'il y a
point des justes,
chapitre 3, verset 10,
pas même en seul.
Il n'y a personne
qui cherche à Dieu,
personne qui glorifie Dieu.
Et donc,
c'est un constat universel,
une déclaration biblique
explicite partout.
Et même,
Jean, dans sa lettre,
par rapport au reste du péché,
même chez les chrétiens,
il dit,
« Si nous disons
que nous n'avons pas péché,
nous ne séduisons nous-mêmes
et la vérité n'est point en nous. »
Donc, c'est la réalité universelle.
La condition de l'être humain
n'est pas
de quelqu'un
qui est né neutre
et qui est sous l'influence
d'un milieu
qui puisse les corrompt.
La réalité,
c'est que
la réalité universelle
du péché
fait poser la question
et nous ne trouvons pas
entre nous
des réponses satisfactoires.
Donc,
la réponse
est ce qu'on a appelé
la doctrine biblique
ou l'enseignement biblique
du péché originel.
Donc,
c'est la liaison,
notamment,
entre
toute l'humanité
et cette source
de l'humanité
qui était Adam
et particulièrement Adam
dans sa première transgression.
Donc,
avant de rentrer
plus profondément
à la compréhension
du péché originel,
c'est important pour nous
d'être précis
par rapport à ce qu'il y a péché.
Voilà pourquoi
on est en parenthèse
avec les termes péché
et c'est très enrichissant
pour nous,
au moins,
dans mon parcours
des fois,
c'était vraiment
très profitable
d'avoir une compréhension
plus profonde
les plus bibliques
de ce qu'il y a
les péchés
selon la description biblique.
Et comment nous pouvons
les faire ?
Nous pouvons,
par exemple,
croiser tous les termes
bibliques
ou les principaux termes
qui décrivent
les péchés
et les conceptions
bibliques
qui expliquent
les péchés aussi.
Donc,
par exemple,
dans la Bible,
on a un nombre
de termes
très intéressants
pour parler de péché.
Donc,
déjà,
la définition
la plus essentielle
du terme
le plus récourant
signifie tout simplement
rater la cible.
Ok ?
sortir du schéma.
Et donc,
les péchés,
c'est d'avoir
quelque part
une égalisation
de ce pourquoi
on a été créé
et nous ne sommes plus
en train de vivre
selon les buts
de notre existence.
Étant créé
par un Dieu bon,
par un Dieu juste,
c'est clair
que ce qu'on devrait vivre
serait le mieux
pour nous-mêmes,
la vie la plus noble
on devrait aspirer
le maximum
qu'il est possible
de vivre
cette vie d'amour,
cette vie belle
pour laquelle
Dieu nous a créés,
mais la réalité,
c'est que nous ratons
la cible.
Nous ne sommes pas
en train de vivre
et voilà pourquoi
dans la définition
du péché,
nous allons comprendre
qu'il ne sait pas
tout simplement
rater la cible
dans la manière
dont intentionnellement
on va rater
la cible,
comme dans un espoir
par exemple.
on ne va pas voir
des sportifs
en cherchant
à rater
intentionnellement,
mais c'est aussi
de rater
l'opportunité
de vraiment
arriver
au point maximal,
au centre
de la cible.
Et donc la réalité,
c'est que nous tous,
on peut pécher
par transgression,
mais on peut pécher
aussi par
ne pas profiter
de toutes les opportunités
qu'on a
pour vivre
une vie encore plus belle.
C'est la négligence
même envers
les bonnes actions
qu'on pourrait faire,
qu'on devrait faire.
Donc ce n'est pas
qu'il y a la négation,
mais c'est aussi
l'omission,
donc rater la cible.
Il y a la notion
des déroutes
qui va avec.
Il y a cette notion
générale
des manques
ou pertes
d'intégrité,
de n'être plus
en ensemble,
cette notion
des fragmentations
ou des manques
d'entièreté.
Donc l'être humain,
quand on n'arrive
pas à vivre
une vie belle,
symétrique,
un peu comme on est
en train de voir
dans les fruits de l'esprit
qui sont tous
des vertus
interdépendantes
qui se nourrissent
mutuellement
et qui doivent
toujours se présenter.
Et donc on sait très bien
que parfois
quand on rate
certaines choses,
quand on transgresse
certaines choses
dans nos vies,
c'est la sensation
de s'autodétruire,
de s'effragmenter,
de s'éparpiller
dans la vie.
Et donc c'est cette notion
des manques d'intégrité
et manques
de véracité
ou d'authenticité.
C'est de ne plus être
en être humain
comme on devrait être.
Il y a aussi
des termes bibliques
qui parlent
du péché
en termes
des révoltes,
des rébellions,
d'insoumission
à cette autorité légale
qui est Dieu
et donc cette notion
vraiment d'être
activement
en train d'agir
contraire
à ce qui est
la volonté de Dieu
et à Dieu lui-même.
Et il y a aussi
cette conception
des transgressions
de la loi.
Donc pour la majorité
des termes
qu'on a considérés
jusqu'ici,
on voit les péchés
de manière
très naturelle.
C'est-à-dire
on est en train
d'agir contrairement
à la nature,
à l'ordre,
à ce qu'on devrait faire.
Mais pour ces deux derniers,
il y a cette notion
des dieux étant
l'autorité suprême
et sa loi révélée,
en fait,
sa volonté révélée
et nous sommes là
en train de casser
délibérament
la loi des dieux
ou une alliance
avec Dieu.
Donc là,
à chaque fois
qu'on commet
les moindres péchés,
c'est comme si on était
en train de casser
notre alliance
avec Dieu.
Il y a donc
associé à la notion
du péché
la notion
des coupabilités
qui n'est pas
tout simplement
une conséquence
du péché.
Attention,
car comme on a été
créé
pour être pur,
pour être droit,
pour être juste
à tout instant
de la vie,
nous sommes
doublement
coupabilisés.
d'abord,
car nous sommes
en train
de transgresser
ce qu'on devrait faire
et nous ajoutons
à la transgression
la coupabilité
qui impliquera
dans la nuisance
de nos vies,
dans la punition.
Et donc,
en plus de la transgression
en soi,
nous sommes en train
de nous autodétruire
à cause de la condamnation
à la condition
à laquelle on s'est mis.
On est en train
de rajouter
une statue,
une position
qui est en soi-même
pécheresse,
la condition
des coupables.
Et donc,
les péchés
sont appelés aussi
infidélité,
trahison,
vanité,
présomption,
futilité
et donc autonomie
au lieu de se mettre
à la volonté de Dieu.
Et il y a aussi
cette notion
de tordre,
corrompre
et la notion
d'anormalité,
donc d'agir
au contraire
de ce pourquoi
Dieu avait ordonné
ou créé.
C'est la direction
du chaos,
c'est la direction
qui va s'éloigner
des dieux.
Et donc,
c'est une transgression,
c'est une abomination
et c'est aussi
l'empiété.
Et ça,
c'est le point
le plus important
par rapport au péché
car non seulement
ces termes
et ces conceptions
nous aident
à comprendre
ce qu'est le péché,
mais le péché,
il est toujours
traité dans la Bible
comme quelque chose
qui est avant tout
dirigé envers Dieu.
Le péché est toujours
quelque chose
qui nous faisons
frontalement
en opposition à Dieu.
Voilà pourquoi David,
quand il est en train
de confesser ses péchés
pour la trahison
d'Urias,
c'est le cas
avec Bathsheba,
il va dire
« Seigneur,
j'ai péché
contre le ciel
et contre toi ».
Donc,
c'est clair
que son péché
était contre un être humain,
mais comme
la noblesse
de l'être humain
ce qui rend
les péchés graves,
c'est le fait
que tous les êtres humains
ont été créés
à l'image de Dieu.
Et donc,
de maltraiter l'être humain,
de faire les moindres péchés
contre l'être humain
et avant tout,
comme celui-là
était en train
de pécher contre Dieu.
Et indépendamment
de la noblesse
de l'être humain,
comme nous vivons
toujours devant
les yeux de Dieu,
c'est devant Dieu
que nous sommes toujours
en train de pécher.
Voilà pourquoi
on va dire
que les secrets
fondamentaux
de la piété,
c'est de vivre
à chaque instant
corandéo,
devant Dieu,
devant les yeux
des dieux.
Car c'est là
où,
même si mon semblable
est en train
de me provoquer,
me faire mal,
ma réaction
ne sera pas
en réaction
envers lui,
mais sera
qu'est-ce qui
plaît à Dieu
pour moi
que je fasse maintenant,
qu'est-ce qui va être
agréable à Dieu.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant,
les péchés,
attention,
c'est de manière
très didatique
comme j'essaie
d'expliquer
à mes enfants,
il y a
ces deux aspects
liés toujours
au péché.
Donc,
par exemple,
si on prend
un pédophile
qui a agressé
un enfant,
on va dire
que cette personne,
elle mérite
d'être punie
à la hauteur
de son péché,
de sa transgression,
qu'elle mérite
d'être emprisonnée.
Mais nous savons
que la relation
qu'on aura
envers ces pécheurs
ne sera pas
tout simplement
une réaction
apathique.
On ne va pas
les traiter
tout simplement
selon la loi.
Ce n'est pas
qu'il y ait
la transgression.
Cette personne
devient devant nos yeux,
devant les yeux
de la société,
quelqu'un
qui est dégoûtant,
abominable.
Et c'est exactement
la même chose
qui se passe
lorsque Dieu
nous contemple.
Dieu,
il contemple
notre transgression
de la loi
qui mérite
une punition
à la hauteur.
Mais en même temps,
Dieu développe
une abomination
envers nous.
Donc,
tous les êtres humains
dans sa condition pécheresse,
car tous les péchés
sont commis
contre Dieu.
Attention,
attention.
Quand on fait
cette déclaration,
Dieu abomine
les péchés,
mais il aime
les pécheurs,
nous ne sommes pas fidèles
à l'enseignement biblique.
Dieu,
il abomine
les péchés
et les pécheurs.
Et Dieu
a dû régler
radicalement
les péchés.
Donc,
Christ a la croix.
La Bible
est très claire
pour dire
que Christ a dû
souffrir
la punition
de notre transgression,
mais il a dû
boire aussi
la coupe
de l'abomination.
C'était une coupe
de colère,
mais aussi
une coupe
d'abomination.
Il a été fait
péché à cause
de nous,
mais il a été fait
aussi
abomination
ou malédiction
à cause
de nous.
Dieu a dû
traiter Christ
selon l'abomination
qu'on méritait
et selon les transgressions
souffrir
pour qu'il puisse,
si nous sommes associés
à Christ,
même les pires
des pédophiles,
s'il est véritablement
répanti,
pour qu'il puisse
être traité
comme la dignité
et la noblesse
du Fils des dieux
lui-même.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que
les péchés,
avant tout,
avant d'être
tout simplement considérés
comme la transgression
d'une loi révélée,
est une abomination
car les péchés,
il est mesuré
à la proportion
de l'autorité
qu'on devrait obéir.
Donc,
péché contre
un ami à moi
n'est pas la même chose
que des péchés
contre un policier
ou un juge.
Les plus grandes
sont les autorités,
les plus grandes
sont les punitions.
Et donc,
comme tous nos péchés
ont été commis
contre Dieu,
l'éternité à l'enfer
ne suffit pas
pour qu'on soit puni
car son autorité
est suprême.
Et la même chose,
c'est par rapport
à sa dignité.
Donc,
c'est l'opposé
de l'abomination,
c'est la dignité,
l'amabilité
de Dieu.
Comme Dieu est celui
qui mérite
le plus notre amour,
celui qui nous aime
le plus,
c'est une chose
des péchés
contre un ami,
c'est une autre chose
des péchés
contre ma mère
qui m'aime.
C'est beaucoup plus abominable
des péchés
contre ma mère
ou contre un enfant.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que les péchés,
ils méritent
une punition éternelle
et la manifestation
d'une abomination.
Voilà pourquoi
l'enfer,
il est décrit
en termes
des régés,
des séparations,
d'abomination
et en même temps
des souffrances,
des punitions.
Vous comprenez ?
Essentiellement,
transgression
et empiété.
Ces deux éléments
sont très importants
pour qu'on puisse
avoir la perception
et la menace
qui représente
un péché pour nous
jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Ne pas vouloir
attrister
les Saint-Esprits
de cette manière.
Et donc,
les péchés
sont toujours
quelque chose
qui se rapportent à Dieu.
La Bible nous enseigne
que les sièges
du péché
sont la source
des lettres.
Voilà pourquoi
ils contaminent
toutes les facultés
de l'être humain.
Donc,
les péchés,
il n'est pas
quelque chose
qui est commis
à l'extérieur.
Ce n'est pas tout simplement
un acte
commis à l'extérieur.
Ce sont même
les pensées,
les affections
mal placées.
Et donc,
ils se trouvent
assiégés
au cœur
de l'être humain.
Les péchés,
il est absolu,
il est qualitatif.
Ok ?
Cette condition
pécheresse
ou les péchés
en soi,
pour plus qu'on puisse
comparer
entre des péchés
qui méritent
peut-être
une punition
plus grave
ou qui méritent
une abomination
ou qui provoquent
plus importante,
la réalité,
c'est que
quand on compare
les péchés
à l'état
original
des droits
de la nature
parfaite
pour laquelle
on devrait vivre,
les péchés
les décrits
dans la Bible
comme en n'est pas
ayant des dégrés
des ombres.
La pureté,
la droiture,
elle est absolument
sainte et pure.
Dieu est absolument
saint et pur
et à partir du moment
où on commet
les moindres péchés,
on se trouve déjà
en pleine ténèbre
comparativement
à Dieu.
Ok ?
Donc,
les péchés,
il est plutôt
quelque chose
de qualitatif
qu'il est quelque chose
de quantitatif.
et il est aussi
quelque chose
qui n'est pas
tout simplement
la privation
du bien,
qui n'est pas
tout simplement
une déficience,
mais il est décrit
comme quelque chose
de moralement positif,
de commettre
des péchés,
que ce soit par omission
ou par transgression,
c'est d'agir
moralement
en opposition
à Dieu
ou à la sainteté.
Donc,
les péchés
ne peuvent pas
être décrits
tout simplement
comme
les manques
d'une meilleure éducation,
ou des choses
comme ça.
La réalité,
c'est que les péchés
sont moralement
actifs et positifs
dans nos relations.
Il est aussi
plutôt une condition
qu'action,
donc nous commettons
les péchés
car nous sommes
corrompus
de la racine,
de la source,
de l'être.
Et donc,
nous commettons
les péchés
car nous sommes
pécheurs
et pas les contraires.
Et donc,
il est toujours
aussi associé
à cette notion
de coupabilité.
Donc,
celle-ci,
est la condition
universelle
de tous les êtres humains.
Tous les êtres humains,
depuis la chute
d'Adam,
depuis qu'on a
un enregistrement
historique
par rapport
à l'humanité,
nous allons toujours
retrouver
dans chaque individu
cette condition.
Les personnes
pécheresses
gouvernées
par les péchés.
Donc,
voilà ce qu'est
les péchés.
Et donc,
comment nous sommes
arrivés jusqu'ici ?
Pourquoi
parler du péché,
c'est de parler
de quelque chose
qu'on connaît bien
par rapport
à nous-mêmes.
Et donc,
la réponse
biblique,
de la théologie
orthodoxe,
confessionnelle,
c'est cette doctrine
du péché originel.
Donc,
quand on lit
les paragraphes 2,
on voit clairement
cette solidarité
de notre condition
à la condition
d'Adam.
donc,
il dit
« Par ses péchés,
nos premiers parents
ont perdu leur justice
originelle
et leur communion
avec Dieu.
Et nous,
en eux,
et de ces faits,
la mort est venue
sur tous.
Tous sont devenus
morts dans les péchés
et entièrement suyés
dans toutes les facultés
et les parties
de leur âme
et de leur corps. »
Donc,
la Bible,
elle est clairement
en train de tout lier
au péché
originel
d'Adam.
Et certains veulent
nier cette connexion,
pour certains,
l'homme serait
basiquement neutre
et il se corrompt
au fur et à mesure.
Donc,
ils veulent
qui participer
à la coupabilité
d'Adam
à la mesure
où,
effectivement,
ils vont commettre
les transgressions.
Donc,
bien sûr que nous sommes
coupables de tous nos péchés,
mais la Bible,
elle dit clairement
que nous participons
aussi
à la coupabilité
d'Adam
et voilà pourquoi
nous participons
aussi
dans ces conséquences.
Donc,
il y a deux théories
principales
pour expliquer
ce qu'on appelle
les péchés originels
ou notre liaison
au péché d'Adam.
La première,
c'est cette théorie
qu'on appelle
la réaliste
et c'est celle
qui dit en fait
que lorsqu'Adam
a chuté,
comme il était
le premier représentant
de toute l'humanité,
comme toute l'humanité
était en Adam,
génétiquement,
la transmission
de cette corruption
originale
nous a touchés.
Et donc,
c'est cette notion
d'identité
séminale.
Mais il y a un aspect
que nous ne pouvons
pas négliger
car quelque part,
lorsqu'en Hébreu 7,
ça nous dit
que Lévi
était en train
de payer
la dîme
en Abraham,
comme s'il était
dans les rangs
d'Abraham.
Donc,
c'est comme s'il
était en train
de participer
de cette action
car il était
en Abraham,
en potentiel,
si vous voulez.
Et donc,
quelque part,
cette compréhension
des coupabilités,
c'est qu'Adam
était un représentant
naturel aussi
de l'humanité.
Il était un représentant
qui serait
l'héper génétique
et ce n'est pas
qu'il est tout simplement
la transmission
de la corruption
une fois qu'il a échoué
et que sa nature
a souffert la chute,
mais c'est que son action,
car il était
les représentants naturels,
celui en qui nous tous
habitions un jour,
quelque part,
les potentiels
pour notre existence,
si vous voulez.
Donc,
ces actions
nous concernaient aussi.
On était là
en train d'agir
avec lui,
quelque part.
Bien sûr qu'il y a
plein de mystères
et des difficultés
avec cette notion.
Donc déjà,
ça s'apprête
en fait à une conception
de matérialisation
de l'âme.
Donc ça va toucher
à la notion
de comment l'âme
est créée
ou l'âme est transmise.
Et donc ça nous donne
une notion
de matérialisation
de l'âme
qui devient
un mystère pour nous.
Et c'est intéressant aussi
car
une autre difficulté
importante,
c'est que la Bible,
elle n'est jamais
en train de nous
responsabiliser
de tous les péchés
commis par Adam.
Elle est toujours
en train de nous
responsabiliser
tout simplement
envers les premiers
péchés d'Adam.
Et elle n'est pas
en train de nous
coupabiliser non plus
de toute notre
ascendance généalogique,
des péchés
de nos pères,
de nos grands-pères
et de toute cette
descendance
des postérités
d'Adam.
Et donc c'est clair
et explicite
dans la Bible
qu'il y a
des bases bibliques
qui puissent jouer
pour expliquer
la transmission
de la corruption
de péché,
de la conséquence
mais pas forcément
trouver ici
une base
pour expliquer
comment nous avons
participé
à la coupabilité
d'Adam.
Et vous pouvez
comprendre en fait
la tentation
de dire
au moins on était
là en train
de pécher aussi
quelque part.
C'est plus facile
d'accepter
cette coupabilité
dans notre sens
des justices
bien corrompue.
Mais la Bible
elle est encore
plus explicite
pour nous conduire
envers ce qu'on
appelle
les fédéralismes.
Une autre difficulté
avec cette notion
c'est qu'on sait
très bien
que la nature
du Christ
était une nature
parfaitement harmonique
entre sa nature
divine et humaine.
Mais si par exemple
nous étions tous
en train de pécher
en Adam,
la participation
des Christ
dans une nature
humaine
pourrait être
aussi représentée
comme quelque chose
qui avait commis
ses péchés
en Adam aussi
et coupable
avec Adam.
C'est clair pour vous
la difficulté ici ?
Et donc là
on doit s'arrêter
et ne pas donner
un pas dans cette direction
car on sait clairement
que la Bible affirme
cette justice
totale
de la part
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et donc
les fédéralismes
ils montrent
qu'Adam
il était
comme on vient
de lire
en Romance 5
les représentants
fédéral
de toute l'humanité.
Donc l'idée
c'est l'idée
d'alliance.
Cela s'harmonise
avec la liaison
seulement
à la culpabilité
du premier péché
comme la Bible
nous présente.
Cela semble
permettre
une compréhension
moins conflictuelle
avec l'incarnation
du Christ
car on peut imaginer
que Christ
et Adam
sont les seuls
qui nous sont présentés
par la Bible
comme les représentants
de toute la race humaine
les Christ
représentants
de la nouvelle création
et Adam
représentant
de toute la création
l'humanité
à partir de lui.
Et donc là
on voit
de quelle manière
Christ aurait pu
participer
véritablement
à la nature
humaine
sans avoir
la contamination
qu'il a prise
en fait
de cette nature
qui est venue
des maris.
Et donc là
c'est intéressant
ça s'harmonise mieux
avec ça
et en plus
ça explique
en fait
comment
il a
pu porter
sur lui
notre coupabilité
lorsqu'il nous est
représenté
à la croix
comme Romain 5
que nous montre
clairement.
Et donc là
la doctrine
la plus évidente
celle qu'on trouve
dans la confession
des fois
c'est que nous
avons été
représentés
par Adam
en tant que
notre représentant
fédéral.
Une illustration
donc un épisode
biblique
qui illustre bien
cette réalité
c'est par exemple
la manière
dont Israël
était assiégé
par les Philistins
et Goliath
a été choisi
comme un représentant
des Philippans
pour se disputer
avec un représentant
d'Israël.
Et donc
ce qui David
allait souffrir
dans ce cas
représenterait
la souffrance
de toute la nation.
Et donc
la représentation
fédérale
c'est ça
la leçon
de David
de Goliath
c'est pas moi
contre les géants
de ma vie
c'est la représentation
de comment Christ
va régler
les problèmes
avec les péchés.
Et donc
c'est un Christ
qui va
ou un David
qui représente
les Christ
et qui va
porter
avec lui
en tant que
représentant
les destins
quelque part
de toute Israël.
Et donc
c'est comme ça
que nous voyons
la manière
dont nous sommes
échoués en Adam
et la manière
dont nous pouvons
trouver les saluts
en Jésus Christ.
Donc les deux
paragraphes
les paragraphes
deux qu'on a déjà lus
et les paragraphes
trois
donc les paragraphes
deux
surtout la deuxième
partie
et nous en eux
ok
et de ces faits
la mort est venue
sur tous
et tous sont devenus
morts dans les péchés
et entièrement
suyés
dans toutes les facultés
et les parties
de leur âme
et de leur corps.
Et donc
les paragraphes
trois
un paragraphe nouveau
pour nous.
Donc puisqu'ils étaient
la souche
du genre romain
et par les vouloirs
des dieux
ils représentaient
toute l'humanité
la coupabilité
du péché
a donc été
amputée
et la nature
corrompue
a été transmise
par eux
à toute leur
prostérité
par les processus
normal
de la génération.
Leurs descendants
sont maintenant
conçus
dans les péchés
et sont
par nature
des enfants
des colères
des serviteurs
de péchés
assujettis
à la mort
et à toutes sortes
de misères
spirituelles
temporelles
et éternelles
à moins que
les seigneurs
Jésus
ne les libèrent.
Donc c'est très
important de remarquer
ici
comme c'est la position
aussi de Lloyd-Jones
que nous ne devons pas
devant les mystères
abandonner
quand on a pensé
à ces deux théories
les réalismes
ou les fédéralismes
on n'a pas besoin
de choisir
entre
ces deux-là.
Il y a une portion
intéressante
qu'on peut trouver
dans cette condition
et il nous semble aussi
dans les paragraphes 3
qu'au commencement
puisqu'ils étaient
la souche
du genre roman
donc quelque part
ça associe
au fait
qu'ils étaient
la souche
la possibilité
que la coupabilité
soit liée
aussi à ça.
Ok ?
Mais
c'est clair
que les portions
les plus explicites
nous dirigent
plus à cette notion
du fait
que Dieu
a choisi lui-même
par les vouloirs
de Dieu
il représentait
toute l'humanité.
C'est là
où on doit être
vraiment explicite
même si l'autre partie
reste un mystère
pour nous.
Par contre
pour la transmission
des conséquences
du péché
la transmission
naturelle
elle fait partie
aussi
de cette corruption.
Ok ?
Car une fois
les péchés commis
la transgression commise
la punition
apportée à Adam et Ève
une fois ces changements
ont eu lieu
chez eux
ça va être communiqué
aussi
naturellement.
Voilà comment
c'est expliqué
dans la confession
des fois
et quand on essaie
de mieux comprendre
la doctrine
du péché originel
nous pouvons identifier
ici
d'autres doctrines
qui expliquent mieux
ce qu'il y a
les péchés
originels.
Donc quelle est
cette signification ?
Donc voilà
les termes
péchés originels
ne signifient pas
ils ne peuvent jamais
signifier
que le péché
a fait partie
de la constitution
originale de l'humanité
que lorsqu'Adam et Ève
étaient
exposés
à ces tests
du fruit
de l'arbre de la vie
ou de la connaissance
du bien et du mal
que les péchés
étaient déjà
chez eux.
Ça la Bible
elle est explicite
catégorique
et claire.
Ils étaient
parfaitement
spirituellement
et moralement
créés.
Par contre
cela signifie
que notre condition
pécheresse
aujourd'hui
est liée
directement
à leur première
transgression.
Il y a trois aspects
par rapport
à la conception
du péché originel
qu'il faut qu'on garde.
Le premier
c'est que
les péchés
de l'humanité
sont dus
à la racine
de l'humanité
à Adam
et sa transgression
primaire.
C'est ça
que la Bible
fait
de manière
explicite.
Elle va lier
nos transgressions
à ce que la Bible
révèle
comme étant
les premiers
péchés
d'Adam.
La deuxième
chose
que cela veut dire
c'est une conséquence
de cette réalité
c'est que
depuis notre naissance
nous sommes
dans une condition
pécheresse.
Nous sommes
construits en iniquité
nous sommes nés
dans les péchés.
Donc
comme conséquence
du fait
que nous avons
hérité la corruption
et la coupabilité
d'Adam
toute l'humanité
est née
dans cette condition.
Donc c'est
dès l'origine
voilà pourquoi on parle
des péchés originels
à cause
de la transition
originale d'Adam
nous
dès notre origine
personnelle
sommes nés aussi
dans les péchés.
Et le troisième aspect
c'est que
cette contamination
a son siège
à l'origine
ou la source
de l'être humain.
Je vous ai rappelé
déjà
que
l'être humain
est composé
d'une partie matérielle
et d'une partie immatérielle.
Il devrait être
un être intégral
inséparable
car
nos émotions
ont impact
sur nos corps
nos corps
ont des impacts
sur nos émotions
et donc
il y a toute cette
harmonie
cette symétrie
qui devrait être
équilibrée parfaitement.
Malheureusement
à cause de la transgression
et à cause du péché
nous nous trouvons
dans une condition
aujourd'hui
où
la contamination
a eu lieu
au siège
des lettres
au cœur
et cela va contaminer
notre raisonnement
notre volonté
nos émotions
et toutes les facultés.
Et donc par là
on veut dire
que les péchés
originels
veulent nous dire
que dès la source
de l'origine
de notre être
nous sommes corrompus
et voilà pourquoi
toutes nos actions
sont tachées
par les péchés.
Et bien sûr
quand on est devant
une telle explication
que nous sommes
dans cette condition
tragique
à cause
de la coupabilité
de la première transgression
d'Adam
nous devons avoir
beaucoup de confiance
envers la révélation
biblique
et beaucoup
d'humilité
car notre sens
de justice
est comme
des langes
suillés
selon la Bible
et nous n'avons
qu'un sens
de justice
car Dieu
nous a créés
avec ça.
Donc la seule
racine ultime
des crises morales
des crises existentielles
c'est ce que Dieu
lui-même
a gravé
dans nos consciences
dans notre moralité
dans nos cœurs
et donc là
il faut
sous la peine
de rejeter
l'enseignement biblique
sous la peine
de rejeter
la parole
de Dieu elle-même
nous devons
embrasser
cet enseignement
notre coupabilité
est liée
au premier péché
d'Adam
qui était
notre représentant
et donc la Bible
l'enseigne
de manière claire
catégorique
et explicite
et donc
les péchés originels
il est distingué
entre deux aspects
principaux
ok
la coupabilité
originelle
et la pollution
donc voilà
comment nous
nous arrivons
à cette déclaration
par les textes
de la confession
donc
au paragraphe 3
ils représentaient
toute l'humanité
la coupabilité
du péché
a donc été
amputée
et la nature
corrompue
a été transmise
par eux
à toute leur
postérité
et donc
la pollution
originelle
à avoir
avec la corruption
qu'ils ont expérimenté
comme conséquence
de la transgression
et la coupabilité
elle a été aussi
communiquée
à nous tous
donc la coupabilité
originelle
affirme
que nous sommes
nés
sous la peine
de la loi
et de la justice
qui a retombé
dans la condamnation
d'Adam
et que nous méritons
cette peine
et que nous sommes
en réalité
coupables
du péché
originel d'Adam
donc à nouveau
quand on considère
les transactions
ou les relations
entre les nations
nous pouvons comprendre
comment ces représentations
fonctionnent
ok
donc si on a choisi
un représentant
et que ces représentants
prennent des décisions
qui peuvent nous concerner
si devant
une autre nation
nous sommes devenus
des ennemis
car le président
a pris des mauvaises décisions
toute la nation
sera prise
comme ennemi
vous comprenez
la coupabilité
et les conséquences
des mauvaises décisions
de notre représentant
sera une coupabilité
qui touche
à toute la race
et donc là
c'est la manière
dont la Bible affirme
clairement
un roman 5
que nous avons lu
et je pense
que c'est important
qu'on relise
à nouveau
ces passages
pour remarquer
de manière plus claire
qu'il y a
deux aspects ici
il y a la coupabilité
et la pollution
et de la même manière
ça nous donne
les bases aussi
pour comprendre
comment les Christ
il enlève
la coupabilité
et il enlève
aussi la pollution
donc il y a
ces deux aspects
la pollution
et la coupabilité
donc roman 5
verset 12
c'est pourquoi
comme par un seul homme
le péché est entré
dans le monde
et par le péché
la mort
et qu'ainsi la mort
s'est étendue
sur tous les hommes
parce que tous
ont péché
la mort ici
elle est la représentation
on va dire
empirique
de la condamnation
de toute l'humanité
car jusqu'à la loi
les péchés
étaient dans le monde
or les péchés
n'est pas amputés
lorsqu'il y a point
des lois
cependant la mort
a régné
depuis Adam
jusqu'à Moïse
même sur ceux
qui n'avaient pas péché
par une transgression
semblable à celle d'Adam
donc là c'est pour montrer
de manière très claire
que la mort
nous touche
non car
on a reçu
postérieurement
une loi
et on a transgressé
aussi cette loi
mais
cette mort
nous touche
car nous avons participé
à la condamnation
du premier péché
d'Adam
lesquels
est la figure
de celui
qui devait venir
donc c'est à dire
dans quel sens
Adam était la figure
de celui
qui devait venir
car il a été la figure
en tant
un représentant
de toute la race
mais Dieu avait déjà
pour plan A
prendre cette figure
comme un représentant
d'un représentant
infiniment supérieur
de notre race
qui serait celui
de notre rédemption
donc mais
il n'a pas
pardon
voilà
mais il n'en
on n'en est pas
du don
comme de la faute
car si plusieurs
ont péri
par la faute
d'un seul
et donc là
c'est les singuliers
la référence
à une faute spécifique
combien plus
la grâce des dieux
et les dons
par la grâce
d'un seul homme
Jésus Christ
ont-ils abondé
pour plusieurs
et donc ici
ce n'est pas
l'universalisme
pour les saluts
ce sont les plusieurs
qui s'est rensovés
les plusieurs
qui étaient représentés
par Christ
et il n'est pas
du don
comme de ceux
qui est arrivé
par un seul
qui a péché
car les jugements
donc là
l'aspect condamnation
donc les jugements
ont été par un seul
homme pour la
condamnation
donc culpabilité
jugement
mais les dons
de la grâce
ont été par plusieurs
fautes
pour la
justification
donc la justification
c'est un langage
d'enlèvement
des coupabilités
c'est une déclaration
légale
Dieu qui peut
nous déclarer
juste
car Christ
est venu
enlever
la coupabilité
du péché
car il était
en représentant
des parfaites
obéissances
droitures
et donc
si par la faute
d'un seul
la mort
a régné
par lui seul
combien plus
ceux qui reçoivent
l'abondance
de la grâce
et du don
de la justice
régrèrent-ils
dans la vie
par Jésus Christ
lui seul
il en est
donc
comme par un seul
acte
de justice
pour tous
les hommes
en justification
des vies
car comme par la
désobéissance
d'un seul homme
beaucoup ont été
rendus pécheurs
de même
par l'obéissance
d'un seul
beaucoup
seront rendus
justes
la loi
est intervenue
pour que l'offense
fût multipliée
mais là où les péchés
abondaient
la grâce
est surabondée
afin que comme
les péchés
arrivent dans la mort
de même
la grâce
règne par la justice
en vue de la vie
éternelle
par Jésus Christ
notre Seigneur
donc on revient
à cette déclaration
car comme
par la désobéissance
d'un seul
beaucoup ont été
rendus pécheurs
de même
par l'obéissance
d'un seul
beaucoup
seront rendus
justes
vous voyez la distinction
c'est à dire
condamnation
mort
ok
coupabilité
justifiée
déclarée juste
par contre
on n'est pas
qu'est déclarée juste
on a été aussi
rendu
juste
vous comprenez
la différence
enlèvement
non seulement
de la coupabilité
de péché
mais aussi
enlèvement
de la pollution
de péché
beaucoup
seront
rendus justes
ces deux aspects
sont clairement
dans ces passages
et c'est les passages
par excellence
pour comprendre
de quelle manière
explicite
donc c'est
c'est impossible
vraiment
pour plus
que nous ayons
des crises
considérer
quels sont les dangers
et quels sont les risques
de vous prolonger
dans vos crises
moi j'ai aussi des crises
mais la réalité
c'est que
devant un texte
si explicite
qui est en train
de lier
notre condamnation
à la coupabilité
du premier
péché d'Adam
c'est un Dieu juste
qui est en train
de les déclarer
et non seulement
la Bible est explicite
c'est qui rend impossible
ok
une autre interprétation
la réalité
c'est que
si je veux lutter
contre ces catégories
ces arrangements
si on peut dire comme ça
nous sommes en train
de lutter
contre la possibilité
de trouver notre salut
en Christ lui-même
car c'est de cette manière
par un représentant
par la perfection
de son obéissance
que je peux trouver
mon salut
et donc là
on voit
de quelle manière
la Bible nous enseigne
cette coupabilité
donc certains veulent s'opposer
car ils ne veulent pas
avoir cette idée
d'être coupable
du péché d'un autre
d'autres
cherchent à aller
un peu plus loin
et ils vont dire
ok
j'ai compris
que comme il a
été coupable
et qu'il a été puni
et donc je suis né
dans les péchés
et cette pollution
dans laquelle je suis né
fait de moi
déjà coupable
et ça c'est vrai
car nous sommes coupables
aussi de notre condition
et de la manière
dont on pêche
mais la réalité
c'est que la Bible
associe
au péché original
d'Adam
notre coupabilité
aussi
et voilà pourquoi
nous avons
cette grâce
en Jésus Christ
et donc là
on considère
cette coupabilité
originelle
par cette définition
la coupabilité
est une coupabilité
par amputation
vous voyez
cette catégorie
d'amputation
et c'est absolument
nécessaire
si jamais
Dieu peut nous sauver
si Christ
peut représenter
un grand nombre
devant Dieu
c'est car
sa justice
nous sera amputée
donc un exemple
un jour avec une fille
de 4 ans
j'ai partagé
l'évangile avec elle
j'ai dit
qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec toi
si tu fais des bêtises
à l'école
et elle m'a dit
je suis mise au coin
et la question était
oui
et là je lui ai dit
tu imagines par exemple
si tu as fait
beaucoup de bêtises
et que tu serais mise au coin
que tu n'allais pas
à la récré
à cause de ça
et qu'il y a un copain
à toi
qui était très sage
qui s'est porté
de manière vraiment
très obéissante
lève les doigts
et dit
maîtresse
j'aimerais bien
que ma copine
puisse partir
à la récré
et moi je prends sa place
au coin
donc c'est un peu
décréditer sur elle
l'obéissance
qu'il avait
et lui
prendre sur lui
la punition
qu'elle méritait
et donc
à lui
amputer
la transgression
et la coupabilité
à elle
amputer
l'obéissance
et bien sûr
que Christ
est le seul
capable
de pouvoir
nous créditer
cette obéissance
parfaite
et donc voilà
cette notion
d'amputation
de la même manière
que c'est passé
avec Adam
c'est comme ça
que ça se passe
avec Christ
le deuxième aspect
c'est
cette pollution
originelle
et je pense
que nous allons
devoir l'aborder
la prochaine fois
je ne veux pas
prendre beaucoup
plus de votre temps
je voulais
ouvrir un peu
pour les questions
mais juste
pour vous avancer
la pollution
parle
de cette
conséquence
immédiate
de la coupabilité
originelle
et de quelle
manière
cette notion
des morts
nous a touchés
et à quel point
avec quelle profondeur
nous sommes touchés
par les péchés
dépravations totales
pour comprendre
comment tous les
aires de nos vies
sont contaminées
et incapacité totale
notamment pour ce qui
concerne la possibilité
d'aller envers Dieu
de donner même
les moindres premiers pas
dans la direction
des dieux
car la définition
biblique de notre
condition
elle est vraiment
très grave
donc voilà
on va s'arrêter ici
pour l'instant
mais c'est très important
de finir toujours
avec une note d'espoir
car les mêmes dieux
qui est arrivé
pour apporter
la punition
c'est les dieux
qui a profité
de cette même structure
de représentation
pour nous communiquer
son salut
et la grâce
de notre rédemption